we've been keeping our eyes on denver
where they have a general manager john
elway stepping down while also stepping
up
he really
is stepping out more than anything else
he's got one year left on his contract
and he's cleared a path for a general
manager who if all things go well could
become the next elway next year and be
fully in charge of the football
operation with no real owner there to
answer to george payton after passing on
opportunity after opportunity after
opportunity for the over the years while
he's worked for the vikings now takes
the job six year contract with the
denver broncos and uh you know they move
forward vic fangio's the coach drew
locks the quarterback but you've got a
new guy in charge of the football
operation and that is going to spark
necessarily all sorts of changes sharing
and mike if i'm him i don't take
anything less than a six-year deal he
was smart to get that six-year deal and
there's a reason for it because of the
ownership issue he met for an hour
privately with brittany bolin who's
expected to take over his owner but we
know how messed up that situation is
there with ownership so who knows how
that's going to play out and also you
don't have the the quarterback in line
is it going to be drew lock is he a
franchise quarterback just like sam
darnold i think the jury's still out on
on what his future is and if if he can
be your quarterback so very smart for
for him to get that long-term deal and
get locked up and if it doesn't work out
he's got some money and and some lovers
there to to get out and go somewhere
else so it's very smart on his part
and hopefully he does a great job there
but we're going to find out you know i
think i said this yesterday mike i just
think these gm jobs are much harder to
hire than a coach i mean a coach you
have some evidence by what happens on
the field we don't really know how much
peyton did behind the scenes in
minnesota how responsible he was uh for
for things that they did in minnesota
and
the broncos frankly i don't know how
they would know that either they can
call and ask around but still
you don't have that evidence of of what
they do on the field i think it's much
easier for these teams to hire a head
coach and obviously they strike out on
the head coaches too a lot but i think
it's much easier to see
what a head cut what an assistant coach
can do as a head coach just you have
some evidence of that and i'm not sure
you have that of a guy who's never been
a gm and has been behind the scenes with
the team not just a peyton but to any of
these guys yeah i mean that's a great
point you're taking that leap of faith
that the guy who has had a lesser job
can step into the top job without really
knowing how much influence he's had over
the roster where he's been employed
maybe he's been the weak link and others
have been covering for him although i
know that peyton's been highly respected
and he's a guy that has had
opportunities and has consistently
declined them until this year you
mentioned brittany bowlen
she is the likely candidate from within
the bowling family in this strange willy
wonka competition they have where the
trustees decide who takes over the other
possibility is
they have an impasse within the family
the eight different people who hold
interest in the franchise don't sign off
on brittany bolan they dig in they have
to sell the team that can happen as well
although there's a hybrid outcome here
that may make the most sense and it's
sort of what happened in tennessee not
to get too deep into the ownership weeds
i just want to put this on everyone's
radar screen there's a chance that
maybe somebody who's interested in
buying a team in the future
offers
to buy out the two
and it's my understanding is it's two
out of eight who are really dug in and
would prefer to just see the team sold
make them an offer then let the other
six match it and the two go away with a
big pile of money and the six take over
the team and brittany boland runs the
team that's kind of what happened in
tennessee that could happen
to avoid a sale of the denver broncos
but peyton's got the security to protect
him against an ownership change whatever
may come with that six-year deal
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports